faster together higher
further faster I don't know if that's
right hey we're back on new Rockstars
it's me cassm we're at the screening of
uh the Marvels which just opened today
and um we're here to find out from the
horse's mouth whether or not this movie
is as mixed as the reviews say it is so
come along uh excuse me gentlemen are
you going to go see the
Marvels oh okay yeah oh okay all right
thank you for your time but nobody wants
to see the marel no one wants to first
so far no one
no one's here to see it
so are you going to go see it I'm going
to go see it right now yeah this is the
first one of the first screenings of the
night yep can I get your before thoughts
um I came from Tucson just to watch this
movie in California you came from
Arizona yep that's Tucson in Arizona you
came just to watch it here they don't
have this movie playing in Arizona they
do actually but the fans over here are
much better than in Arizona like really
respectfully of course I'm kind of
looking forward to it it seems like has
a lot of good potential with the
characters the first time I came here in
AMC bbang it was the screening for
Spider-Man no way home oh yeah it was
like an earthquake inside the theater
and I was like every Marvel movie I'm
going to fly to California to watch the
same theater been a little bit
disappointed with the past Marvel movies
this this is uh you with Bri Larson here
this is is Hy sunfield as well is that
your favorite Marvel character my top
three like to be honest it's Captain
Marvel SC witch and Kate Bishop like
these three are so amazing we' set up a
table here today to get some
constructive criticism uh Marvel's sort
of in a little bit of a slump it that's
okay we're going to get um everyone's
thoughts on how to make it better the
Marvel's question mark WTF what the okay
so I wasn't excited about the first
Marvel's movie I'm not too excited about
the feuture going forward with Brie
Larson as Captain Marvel okay but you're
here to see the movie I Am constructive
are going off track okay let's go back
to the Bas let's go back all right by
the way I thought this is a go ahead
we'll take it no no no we'll take it
okay so you just came out of a screening
yes is it your favorite Marvel movie yes
my favorite movie in the MCU is
Spider-Man no home I watched it like
maybe 60 times right now how many 60
times 16 or 60 6 that's Abdullah that's
a lot of
times that's nothing yeah I mean there's
just there there is kind of an
inundation of content right now I think
in general um but I still very much
enjoyed it I know there's a lot of
superhero fatigue that's talked about um
do you believe in that I guess no I mean
I think I could take superheroes all day
yeah exactly so I'm that cram it in up
me whatever I want superheroes all the
time you will very much enjoy this when
you're done turn it into to the teacher
okay I'm I'm the teacher I feel like
you're uh a rare specimen because I I go
online and everyone's telling me
Marvel's going through like a slide
they're having a tough time what what
what are they talking about I don't
believe it to be honest what's going on
with Marvel right now does anybody like
Marvel right now I mean I think that
they're definitely at a weird crossroads
right now uh I do think that once
endgame finished there was a certain
void we haven't got any Avengers movies
since end game but if you put a lot of
faith in Marvel they're going to
surprise us a lot not only did they
basically they try to make all the
chicks into dudes they took all the
chicks all right they took all the dudes
and also made them chicks like what the
what are you doing we need at least
where where's the mes well out of 10
let's give this movie a rating probably
like seven seven or eight that's pretty
high yeah yeah I mean I I very much
enjoyed it listen uh they can't all be
10 yeah solid eight yeah I would give an
an eight out of 10 as well um okay is
that just so you don't fight in the car
on the way home is that a real eight no
that is a real eight um but for
different reasons so I'm a huge fan of
Iman balani she's fantastic I think the
young actor playing uh M Marvel is
absolutely fantastic she is the m Marvel
of my dreams honestly I think that like
her fangirling just comes from such
a a genuine Place Captain Marvel is the
worst show ever and I hate it and it's
like oh the Miss Marvel show Miss marel
you're trying to be so woke and it's not
working oh okay you just don't like the
woke stuff no I I think it's too much
it's too much wow I would have never
thought that that blew my mind that's
supposed to be their intended audience I
think
we might be in trouble the moment I get
back in my chair and my apartment I'm
watching the season finale of Loki have
you been watching new rock stars
coverage of Loki of course of course you
have every moment thank you for saying
that wouldn't miss it are you kidding me
like look I we're doing before after
reactions we just got your after
reaction would you guys um uh mind
giving me a a before like hey I'm we're
about to go see the movie we're really
excited and and we'll pretend hey we're
about to go see the marbles you know I'm
really excited for well I hope you guys
enjoy it and maybe we can catch you on
the way back yeah sounds good sure so
long all right thanks than see you go
all the way
up stay on them I have a screening for
5:45 and 8:3 you're going to see it
twice just tonight yeah and even
tomorrow as well they could have taken
the escalator they chose the steps
Avengers endgame I watched it in
theaters 110 times in Kuwait you saw
endgame 110 times yep 10 times and I
even skipped a a final exam in my high
school just to win just to go to the
screen did you graduate oh I guess we
did let make sure they do this he you
you're you're like one of the most pure
Marvel fans I've ever met and I hope
somebody recognizes
that got him what do you want to say to
Kevin feige um the man the myth the
legend out there Legend as right now I
think Marvel should pull back it's like
okay remember when we only had one movie
a year and then they increased it to two
yeah let's fix it up let's fix it up
Kevin let's do what we can go back to
movies take a break on your TV shows
give your VFX artist space give them
some time to breathe that's a great
Point there's a whole bunch of VFX in
this movie it looks fantastic yeah but
there are moments where it's just like
one of my truly dreams do come true to
me is just to be invited in Avengers
secret War World premiere that's my only
wish that I want Kevin get abdala to the
secret War World premiere we're talking
two years three uh no uh four years four
years yes to release on May 6th 2027 you
already you already know the dates oh
yeah appreciate your work a lot Kevin
and uh love to see it and uh I'll keep
paying money to see it higher further
faster
together thank you so much enjoy your
screening I hope you really enjoy it if
we're still here come back and tell us
what you thought about it of okay
because your opinion matters more than
anyone else's I've met I really want to
know what you think of it okay app all
right thank you so much yeah yeah okay
so they're going to a screening at
5:45 that means we've got to be here for
another two
hours I didn't really think about
that maybe we'll just let's go find
Abdullah let's just get his
thought
the cancer's
[Music]
back excuse me never do that again I'm
sorry it wasn't on purpose so your mom
passed away while
flipped hat C no one was there how's the
movie good okay we have to leave why cuz
I'm I can't wait that long I'm
hungry so I I need your movie review
okay all right tell me what you think
about it yeah so far so good I mean the
flashback was so great okay yeah so I'm
just kind of enjoying the movie right
now okay yeah okay thank you so much
appr have a great day thank
you she was the
best
sorry all right it was hard to see but I
got him you found him yeah him he said
he uh enjoyed the flashback scene and
but he was in the middle of watching it
so I couldn't give a full review did the
movie seem good uh movie seemed
[Music]
fine